you mentioned a few times um that
about counseling what is something
you've learned about yourself
one of my missions with this show is to
norm like
going spelunking into your heart and
into your past and then
um finding ways that you can um
change your relationships and change
your your life in a positive way
just a little bitty thing sometimes it's
big things uh two things
i'm very selfish okay my needs and wants
like i like
yes they're the same they are or you're
asking no i'm saying for a selfish
person needs and wants are the exact
same thing
yes yes uh and in the same toke back to
the sadness thing i can avoid pain
i will avoid pain i can avoid
tough conversations if something
sad something that should make someone
sad happens
parenting marriage whatever you fill in
the blank i tend to
check out and say it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be okay
and by doing that creates that that
level of
unauthenticity okay not vulnerabilities
i don't allow myself to go there
in a relationship sometimes so when you
over over the years in counseling you've
probably had to practice that
yes what give some language to what it
feels like when you do
um when you practice sitting with
someone who's just sad
do i practice sitting with someone just
that no like like
yeah so i mean engaging my feelings
would be to be able to verbalize and
communicate
exactly what i'm thinking and feeling
without filtering okay and i even say
that out loud i'm like okay
i don't want to do this because i don't
want i don't want pain for you i don't
pay for me
but i'm choosing to have this
conversation because i love you
and i want a better relationship and so
here are the places you've hurt me
here's the you know the sadness the fear
the anger
that i was feeling like just being able
to lay it out
okay and be okay with that because
here's the deal too this took many
hundreds of dollars in counseling
you can't control what the other person
does with that that's right and so being
able to go into those conversations
knowing i can't control you i can't
change you
but for me to be able to tell the truth
with what i experienced
is a that's a huge cleansing step and
and when you do that though you know
this but like you're opening yourself up
to be known and that person can choose
to reject it yeah so that's scary
but you do it for the for the
relationships that are worth fighting
for because those are exhausting
conversations so like the people in my
life that are worth fighting for
my family should just be a few people my
marriage yes
a few of my great close friends that
i'll probably put the energy
i'm just kidding rachel never has
these conversations with me she's like
oh oh hmm
and then she moves on it's fine
everybody it's fine yeah but there's
like the
yeah the people that you're like no i
will fight for that relationship so i
will go there in places like i don't
like to go but i will
in order to be known so
paint me a picture of your physiology
while it's happening
what does that feel like it's weird i've
i mean it's been years so i have to
practice it i'm calm
now okay and i've learned though my
voice
i get bigger with like when people get
insecure they either
turtle or they go big and i go big my
voice will get loud
i'm leaving my body posture i mean i i
get big
yeah yeah yeah so you get you ramp up
for no no i watch myself because when
that starts to happen i can feel it go
so then i have to take a few
i like okay calm back down my language
yeah my tone my speed yeah
all of it so that so for whatever it's
worth are your shows always like this is
it like one big counseling session
your therapist is awesome and here's why
as soon as somebody can make a
connection between
their physical response and their
emotion
that's that is the key right because
then i know
oh wait a minute they're not making me
feel this way
this politician isn't making me feel
this way this is my body responding to
the fact i'm scared
or that i'm nervous or that i'm sad and
so what you just did for folks listening
all 14 of them is give them like
oh i start octaving up my voice and then
i want it right and i start
and that may just be a signal that i'm
scared or i'm uncomfortable
or that being sad in my family was a
no-go
and so i don't want to go there and when
i start feeling like we're entering into
sad space
then my body's like whoa rally the
troops right and whatever that looks
like or
i'm the uh i'm the opposite i turtle up
and say bye
yeah and shut off i get withdrawal
that's right yeah